pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieux connaissez vous l'origine
de l'expression prendre des mesures
draconiennes prendre des mesures
draconiennes
autrement dit des mesures d'une sévérité
exemplaire qui ne souffre aucune
exception
mais d'où sort le qualificatif
draconiens du nom d'un personnage
grecque qui vivait au septième siècle
avant notre ère
un dénommé dragons avec un c alors que
la cité est en proie à la guerre civile
et qu'il faut ramener le calme
ce monsieur est chargé de remettre un
peu d'ordre dans les lois du moment il
faut dire qu'à l'époque le droit n'est
pas écrit il est rendue par des
magistrats qui interprète des coutumes
transmise oralement et des cils bien
souvent à la tête du client et en
fonction de leur intérêt pour assurer la
paix sociale drac on doit mettre les
choses noir sur blanc et définir une
peine correspondant à chaque infraction
seuls quelques bribes de ces textes nous
sont parvenues mais il semble qu'ils n'y
soient pas allés avec le dos de la
cuillère apparemment dracs ont considéré
que toutes les infractions perturbé l'an
dans le public de la même manière et
valait donc la même peine en
l'occurrence lacombe de mort d'où le
caractère sévère et stricte d'une mesure
draconienne
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]